in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to solve inequalities so this is
definitely something important to
understand for the UN revised s80 they
don't always give it to you just as a
straightforward just solve this
inequality they may have acknowledged
slight variation we're going to talk
about some examples like that in this
lesson but first of all I just want to
mention to you if you forgotten and you
just want to remember that if you
multiply or divide by a negative number
what happens to that inequality signs
you remember you know it flips or it
changes directions doesn't affect it if
you add or subtract a negative number
just if you're multiplying or dividing
both sides of equation by a negative
number you yourself in the process of
solving it that mean equality sign flips
let's go through some examples see if
you can pause the video and do these on
your own and we'll go through them
together so first example 1 it just says
which is a solution to the inequality 2x
minus 7 is less than 5 X plus 5 so this
was kind of an easy one they're going to
get progressively more challenging but
so for this first one what do you think
how would you solve it well you can
always do the back substitution
technique you put negative 10 in for
both sides you know solve it see if it
makes you the left side on the right
side if it makes it true if this is left
on the right side but way I'm gonna do
this problem I think is little bit
quicker is just to go ahead and solve it
so i'm going to subtract 5x from both
sides okay so just like solving an
equation you've got negative 3x minus 7
and less than 5 i'm going to add 7 to
both sides we get negative 3x is less
than 12 if we divide by negative 3 what
happens well that inequality sign is
going to flip it means that x is greater
than negative 4 so when you look at the
answers let's see greater than negative
4 well negative 10 is smaller than
negative 4 negative 4 is equal to
negative 4 negative 5 is smaller the
negative 4 so it looks like negative 3
is the only one that's actually greater
than negative 4 so here's negative 4
here's negative 3 here's negative 5 so
we r greater than sugar to the right on
the number line right because you're 0
ok so the best answers let us see
example number 2 it says if 5x plus 8 is
less than or equal to negative 2 what is
the greatest possible value of 5x minus
2 good question right ok well let's take
a look at this now there's a couple
different ways to do this problem but
one
way that I might do it is I might do
something like this see if you can
follow me on this example here so we're
looking at five X minus 2 right so what
can I do to make this equal to 5x minus
2 well i could subtract 10 right from
both sides so that gives us 5x minus 2
is less than or equal to negative 12
right so now it just says you know
what's the greatest possible value well
this has to be less than or equal to
negative 12 less than or equal to so the
biggest city could be would be negative
12 right so negative 12 is going to be
the largest value that's it so you got
it so c4 that's not going to be less
than or equal negative 12 0 that's not
going to be less than equal to negative
12 3 isn't that lesson equal negative 12
negative 12 is the only one that's going
to be you know less than make it this
true and it's the largest that it could
be of course this could be less than
like it could be negative 13 negative 14
so what I did in this problem instead of
solving for x like I probably would
normally do I just try to see what do I
need to do to make this look like 5x
minus 2 a little bit of a shortcut so
that's one way to approach it so now
example 3 it says which ordered pair X
comma Y satisfies the system of
inequalities and they give us some
options now in a problem like this again
you can use the back substitution
technique this represents X&Y right so
we can go ahead and substitute these
values in and see which one makes both
inequalities true the other way to do it
is to graph it either way would work
might be faster this to substitute but
i'll show you the graphing method just
so you kind of have an idea of how that
looks so this is really just like the y
equals MX plus b form of the line so you
can see it's crossing here at three and
has a slope of negative one so that
means we're going you know down 1 over 1
so it's going to look like this and it's
a solid line right and when the Y's are
greater than that means we're shading
above the line see when you have the Y
by itself greater than means your
shading above this one the y intercept
is 1 see y equals MX plus B and the
slope is choose we're going up to over 1
okay so this line looks like this but
this one we're saying y is less than or
equal to or shading below now where does
the lines overlap you can see they're
overlapping ray
here right so which one of these points
is in that region well you can see for
two that looks like it's right there
that's going to make both of the
inequalities true if you look at three
negative five that makes one true but
not the other true one one that makes
you know one true but not the other true
and negative 13 that doesn't make either
of them true so you're looking for you
know points in this overlapping region
so I probably would just do the back
substitution make sure it makes both of
them true not just one but both and you
got it so if you need to review
inequalities you know go ahead and go
through these examples again otherwise
i'll see you in the next lesson